c'est très important comparé cette voix
s'y colle est la petite fille du dernier
potiers de nydel en activité jusqu'à la
fin de la première guerre mondiale
la terre c'était fini donc mon grand
père a changé complètement de métier et
après il ya plus une potier et ma grand
mère quand elle est veuve elle louis son
local à un céramiste de parisiens qui
venus travailler aujourd'hui pour
perpétuer ses savoir faire
colette et son mari propose des stages
de découverte destinée aux petits et
grands
on a travaillé sur le lian li poterie et
fallait l'équipe sommes enfin unis pop
une poterie traditionnelle
donc on essaie de refaire un petit peu
ce qui se faisait
mais où on est on s'en éloigne aussi
beaucoup parce qu'on on travaille plutôt
s'il travaille un peu tout ils
continuent de confectionner ce piché à
tête de chien appelé bout elle
fabriquait annie bel depuis le 19e
siècle il est devenu un des symboles de
la commune ni belle c'est un village de
potiers on a trouvé des traces depuis le
xiième siècle
donc il y a eu énormément potier dans le
village on en a répertorié à peu près
120 entre le
la fin du xvième et le début du xxème
tout le week end le marché des potiers
vous propose de re découvrir cet art le
musée de nivelles dédié est aussi ouvert
pour l'occasion